lebenslänglich gericht verurteilt stehen
rechtsextremisten stefan ernst für den
mord am kasseler regierungspräsidenten
walter lübke impfstoff mit
einschränkungen deutsche impfkommission
will mittel der firma astrazeneca
voraussichtlichen nur für menschen unter
65 empfehlen glück im unglück deutscher
weltumsegler boris herrmann rammt kurz
vor dem ziel ein fischerboot bleibt aber
unverletzt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den nachrichten um 7 arbeitnehmern ist
auch dabei für den sport einige wundern
tor von mir
heute fiel das urteil im prozess um den
mord an regierungspräsident walter
lübcke
das oberlandesgericht frankfurt am main
hat stefan ernst zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt und die besondere schwere der
schuld festgestellt
vorläufiger abschluss eines sie jetzt
schon historischen verfahrens es war
dies der erste mord aus rechtsextremer
gesinnung an einem deutschen politiker
seit 1945
der mitangeklagte marcus h bleibt frei
walter lübcke wird in der nacht auf den
2 juni 2009 10 auf der terrasse seines
hauses aus nächster nähe erschossen
kurze zeit später nimmt die polizei den
rechtsextremisten stefan ernst fest
seinen fremdenhass so die richter heute
projizierte ernst auf walter lübke
der hatte während einer
bürgerversammlung auf der auch ernst war
die aufnahme von flüchtlingen verteidigt
christoph schneider berichtet der
medienandrang zum urteil noch einmal
riesig plakate werden gezeigt
solidaritätsbekundungen für familie
lübke die noch mal persönlich gekommen
ist für die richterinnen und richter des
staatsschutzsenats des olg frankfurt am
main ist erwiesen dass stefan ernst in
der nacht vom ersten auf den zweiten
juni 2009 10 den kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke auf
der terrasse seines wohnhauses im
nordhessischen wolfhagen ist
heimtückisch und aus niedrigen
beweggründen erschoss getrieben von
rassistischen und fremdenfeindlichen
motiven aus sicht des gerichts wollte
ernst mit der ermordung von lüpke andere
politiker einschüchtern
die für weltoffenheit einstanden
zufrieden mit dieser begründung ist die
anklage
der rechtsstaat hat sich wer auf gezeigt
weil er mit dem ihm zur verfügung
stehenden mitteln einen politischen mord
aufgeklärt und mit nachdruck verfolgt
hat der mitangeklagte markus h wird nur
wegen unerlaubten besitzes einer
schusswaffe zu einer bewährungsstrafe
verurteilt und verständnis bei familie
lübke insofern ist es sehr sehr
schmerzlich für die familie jetzt
erleben zu müssen wie die indizien die
aus ihrer sicht eine verurteilung hätten
möglich machen können sollen müssen wie
auch immer dass das nicht geschehen ist
persönlich an die familie lübke gewandt
sagte der vorsitzende richter dass es
ein schweres verfahren gewesen sei auch
für das gericht ja frage an felix
zimmermann ist denn die suche nach der
wahrheit gescheitert zumindest was den
möglichen mittäter markus h betrifft das
gericht hier in frankfurt hat wirklich
fast alle anstrengungen unternommen der
war die wahrheit ans licht zu fördern
doch man muss eben sagen das ist nicht
ganz gelungen einerseits ist eben völlig
unklar die rolle des markus h wie er
beteiligt war
und da geht dann aber natürlich im
rechtsstaat in dubio pro reo im zweifel
für den angeklagten
und so war markus h hier freizusprechen
und ein weiterer freispruch und diesmal
für stefan ernst wegen des vorwurfs des
versuchten mordes an einem irakischen
flüchtlinge wurde ebenfalls
freigesprochen aus mangel an beweisen
allerdings eins ist sicher
stefan ernst hat weiter lübke aus
rechtsextremistischen motiven getötet
was der prozess ja erschreckend vor
augen führt wie gefährdet heutzutage
kommunalpolitiker sind welche lehren
müssen denn nun bezogen werden
nach überzeugung vieler sind die
sicherheitsbehörden erst durch den mord
an weiter lückel aufgewacht was die
priorisierung des kampf gegen rechts
angeht horst seehofer sagte damals es
ist ein anschlag gegen uns alle schuf
hunderte neue stellen für den
verfassungsschutz und das sind also
einerseits die lehren für die
sicherheitsbehörden andererseits sind
auch lernt für die gesellschaft zu
ziehen
denn stefan ernst sah sich in seiner tat
bestärkt dadurch dass es eben tausende
zehntausende hass kommentare im netz
gegen weiter lüttge gab und auf seiner
arbeitsstelle in kassel gab es keinerlei
widerworte
wenn stefan ernsten menschenverachtende
rassistische äußerungen von sich gab
insofern ist die gesellschaft ja ist
jeder einzelne aufgerufen klare position
gegen extremismus jeder art zu zeigen
denn aus taten aus worten wer das worten
können taten folgen
das zeigt nicht nur der mordfall lücke
bedenkenswerte antwort vielen dank der 4
felix zimmermann gleich im anschluss an
unsere nachrichten sehen sie ein zdf
spezial gefahr von rechts urteil im
lipke prozess zur corona pandemie und da
gibt es eine positive entwicklung die so
genannte sieben tage incidents liegt zum
ersten mal seit drei monaten unter 100
nämlich bei 98 das heißt innerhalb einer
woche haben sich 98 menschen pro 100000
einwohner neu mit dem virus infiziert
zum vergleich so stellt sich die sieben
tage incidents grafisch heute da und so
vor gut fünf wochen
damals war der wert mit 197,6 mehr als
doppelt so hoch innerhalb eines tages
meldet das robert-koch-institut gut
17.000 500 neuinfektionen
das sind 2845 weniger als vergangene
mittwoch 9 141 menschen sind in
verbindung mit kobe 19 gestorben
in sachen impfstoffe gibt es eine
meldung die aufhorchen lässt das mittel
von astrazeneca soll in deutschland wohl
nur für 18 bis 64 jährige zugelassen
werden also nicht für die besonders
corona gefährdete gruppe der
das empfiehlt nach einem entwurf der dem
zdf vorliegt die ständige impfkommission
begründung es gebe nicht genug daten für
die wirkung der impfung ab 65
und so könnte der deutsche im plan
durcheinander geraten
christoph distel einer apotheke in
brixton hier verimpft der apotheker
persönlich den stoff von astrazeneca nur
senioren in der schlange so will es das
britische impfprogramm die deutschen
bedenken kümmern hier niemanden und doch
kommen die zu dem schluss dass
astrazeneca spritzen bei uns wir über
64-jährige derzeit tabu sein müssen denn
zur beurteilung der imf effektivität ab
65 jahren liegen aktuell keine
ausreichenden daten vor
nicht etwa sei der britisch-schwedische
impfstoff weniger geeignet als die
anderen zugelassenen wird klar gestellt
aber die sache mit der dünnen datenlage
den schuh muss sich übrigens astrazeneca
selbst anziehen meinen kenner
das problem bei astrazeneca ist dass in
den großen phase-3-studien anfänglich
erst mensch nur patienten mit alltags
von 18 bis 55 eingeschlossen worden sind
und man erst später angefangen hat auch
ältere menschen zu rekrutieren
dabei gibt es sogar eine studie aus dem
dezember prohaska zenica verglichen hat
jüngere menschen ältere menschen dort
die impfstoffe oder die beiden in den
beiden altersgruppen equi valent gab es
also keine hinweise darauf dass es etwas
schlechter funktioniert weil aber sehr
kleine fallzahlen gesundheitsminister
sparen gibt sich entspannt diesen
impfstoff dann halt erstmal für jüngere
aber wichtig für die gruppen für die
jahr zugelassen wird wird er wirksam
sein sonst würde ja nicht zugelassen
und deswegen geht es dann eben darum
auch schnellstmöglich dann wenn der
impfstoff zur verfügung steht die
gruppen für die ja empfohlen ist die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu impfen
doch das gerücht astrazeneca wirke kaum
bei den älteren ist nun mal im umlauf
egal wie falsch da geht vertrauen
verloren mit das wichtigste beim impfen
das impfen organisation und
verfügbarkeit der impfstoffe
das soll am kommenden montag thema eines
gipfeltreffens werden mit dabei
bund länder
und pharmaindustrie die infektionszahlen
gehen ja deutlich zurück und in baden
württemberg wollte man in sachen
grundschule und kitas nun eigentlich
vorpreschen und öffnen
jetzt kommt die absage eine hoch
ansteckende virus variante ist in einer
kita in freiburg ausgebrochen
simon pfanzelt seit wochen betreut anne
müller drei ihrer vier kinder zu hause
sie genießt die zeit sagt sie aber
manchmal ist es auch ein bisschen viel
auch deshalb hat es ja auf kommenden
montag gehofft dann hätten grundschulen
und kitas hier in baden württemberg
eigentlich schrittweise wieder öffnen
sollen
doch das kommt nun anders ich hätte mich
für die kinder gefreut weil ich glaube
ihnen fehlen die sozialen kontakte
lernen in der gemeinschaft in dieser
freiburger kita haben sich mindestens 18
kinder und erzieher mit der
hochansteckenden corona variante aus
südafrika infiziert ein ausbruch der
nervös macht die landesregierung
kassiert ihre eigenen öffnungs pläne
jeder muss 1 vieles geht bei der lage
nicht es wäre ein risiko dass wir nicht
ein bedürfen im interessen aller die
mutanten sind nicht vor der tür sie sind
leider schon gar grundschule am computer
so wird es auch hier in rheinland pfalz
erst einmal bleiben den ab montag
geplanten wechsel unterricht hat die
bildungsministerin heute gestoppt
das war bis gestern so aus als ob er
genau diesen weg zur weiteren öffnung
gehen können
ich glaube es ist wichtig dass man in
situationen auch wenn einem die
entscheidung nicht leicht fallen dann
aber auch verantwortung zeigt und das
tun wir
entspannung für gestresste eltern ist
nicht in sicht denn auch wenn die
infektionszahlen zurückgehen wächst
durch die virusvarianten der druck tja
so sieht es aus die pandemie bleibt eine
herausforderung trotz der sinkenden
infektionszahlen wie geht die
bevölkerung inzwischen mit der krise um
das interessiert das politbarometer
diese woche matthias fornoff hat es
mitgebracht hallo matthias hallo pizza
genannt was denken menschen inzwischen
über corona
und im chaos ja fast drei viertel der
befragten finden dass das impfen bei uns
schlecht läuft die zustimmung zu den
corona maßnahmen dagegen ist weiter groß
nur 14 prozent finden die
einschränkungen übertrieben weniger als
vor zwei wochen eine mehrheit von 56
prozent findet die maßnahmen jetzt
gerade richtig und 28 prozent finden sie
müssten noch härter sein und welche
einschränkungen stören am meisten wir am
meisten stört dass man familie und
freunde nur eingeschränkt treffen kann
das sagen 63 prozent kultur und sport
vermissen 14 prozent am meisten 9
prozent stört vor allem dass sie nicht
reisen können
ähnlich viele vermissen vorrangig in
restaurants zu gehen und wie stehen die
deutschen zu möglichen grenzschließungen
grenzen zu schließen für den
reiseverkehr zwischen eu ländern
es finden 57 prozent richtig 40 prozent
nicht nur die anhänger von fdp und
grünen sind mehrheitlich dagegen
kurzer blick noch auf die politische
stimmung wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre käme die union auf 37 prozent die
spd auf 15 beide unverändert
afg 9 -1 fdp 6 plus 1 linke 7 minus 1
grüne 20 prozent ja und das würde dann
reichen für schwarz-grün oder auch
schwarz rot nicht aber für grün rot rot
interessantes ergebnis vielen dank
matthias jahren das komplette
politbarometer sehen sie im heute
journal um 21 uhr 55 wenn sie mögen in
der zdf- heute- app gibt es alle zahlen
und grafiken aber auch jederzeit
ausführlich zum durchklicken und
nachlesen grenzen dicht machen um das
virus aufzuhalten darüber ist europa bei
einem treffen der innenminister uneins
deutschland plant reisende aus
großbritannien südafrika portugal und
brasilien vorerst nicht mehr ins land zu
lassen
anderswo in der welt gelten bereits
strengere regeln australien etwa
schottet sich gegen alle ausländer ab so
weit wie es geht
aber auch die in die usa dürfen viele
nicht einreisen unter anderem solche die
aus deutschland kommen in europa lassen
großbritannien dänemark belgien oder
auch finnland reisende nur noch in
ausnahmefällen rainer krüger berichtet
finnland schafft fakten einreisen darf
nur noch wer gute gründe hat und einen
negativen schnelltest solche neuen grenz
regeln besser abzusprechen
das ist das ziel am anderen ende von
europa portugal hat den vorsitz beim
video rat der innenminister
handys pandemic tagen in zeiten der
pandemie wollen wir darüber reden wie
wir den erfolg des schengen-abkommens
bewahren können
sie sollten dabei aber nicht nur an
grenzen denken sondern auch an zonen mit
gleicher ansteckungsrate diese könnten
über grenzen hinweg gehen das würde es
den pendlern leicht für sie gilt in
belgien schon eine ausnahme vom
ausreiseverbot das zielt seit gestern
auf urlauber wie diese mit ziel
teneriffa ist jeder reise dringend
notwendig das ist urlaub aber wir haben
rheuma und früchten vom schlechten
wetter
deutschland will keinen stopp für
ausreisen aber für einreisen aus
mutations gebieten es geht schlicht und
einfach um das große ziel den eintrag
eines hoch infektiösen virus noch
deutschland einzudämmen
zu den risikoländern zählt der deutsche
minister übrigens auch den gastgeber
portugal
die pkw maut und ihr scheitern der
untersuchungsausschuss der die rolle der
bundesregierung bei dem geplatzten
projekt beleuchtet beendet heute seine
befragungen als letzter zeuge kam noch
einmal verkehrsminister scheuer der
seine entscheidungen verteidigte er
hatte trotz viel kritik an der pkw maut
festgehalten verträge abgeschlossen
doch dann wurden die mautpläne
vom europäischen gerichtshof gekippt und
jetzt gibt es hohe
schadensersatzforderung matthias feld
hoffe dass urteile maut
untersuchungsausschuss steht quasi fest
die opposition sieht den
verkehrsminister der lüge und des
rechtsbruchs überführt andreas scheuer
hält heute beim schlussakt noch mal
massiv dagegen
ich verstehe den unmut auch über dieses
projekt und die entwicklung dazu fakt
ist aber dass wir rechtens gehandelt
haben scheuer kämpft auch um seine
politische reputation insbesondere die
schadenersatz frage rückt immer mehr in
den mittelpunkt über 500 millionen euro
stehen im raum
in einem zdf interview betont der
mautbetreiber dieses geld habe er nie
gewollt
der bund hat die schadensregulierung für
alle bieter im baut verfahren gleich
angeboten
wir haben diese schadensregulierung
nicht gefördert andreas scheuer sieht
das anders schon die summe sei rein
spekulativ
am letzten vernehmung tag zeigen sich
nach auffassung der opposition aber
erneut ungereimtheiten im umgang mit dem
out vertrag
er hat also einen vertrag unterschrieben
dessen schadensersatz regeln er nicht
kannte
und er hat ihn nachher gekündigt ohne
den genauen höhe des möglichen
schadensersatz zu kennen quasi eine
organisierte verantwortungslosigkeit
jeder schiebt es auf den anderen und
keiner will es gewesen sein
die spd wird aus rücksicht auf die
koalition aber wohl keine direkte schuld
bei andreas scheuer feststellen
deshalb wird der u ausschuss dem
minister kaum gefährlich im gegensatz
zum schadenersatz urteil das soll noch
in diesem jahr fallen ja nun zu dir
norbert und zum sport und zum
sprichwörtlichen glücklich und wird für
den deutschen segler boris herrmann ja
das unglück gestern abend kurz vorm ziel
in frankreich sein schiff kollidiert mit
einem fischtrawler aus der traum vom
ersten deutschen sieg bei der ronde
globe aber das glück hermann bleibt
unverletzt das boot zwar beschädigt aber
erreicht den zielhafen als vierter
es ist eine triumphale rückkehr für
boris herrmann auch ohne einen platz auf
dem siegerpodest
nach 80 tagen hat der 39 jährige
trotzdem gewonnen die sympathien von
hunderttausenden wird so manch
wesentliche erkenntnis gute dinge haben
weil man braucht vielleicht 80 tage bis
zum ziel von frau und ich glaube und das
ist verdammt lange und man muss dran
glauben einfach und ich hätte das ding
fast gewinnen können hätte der
wahl-hamburger tatsächlich wäre er nicht
in der allerletzten nacht wenige stunden
vor dem ziel mit diesem fisch orla
kollidiert die ursache dafür noch unklar
dc explorer konnte mit gebrochener
tragfläche nur noch ganz langsam weiter
segeln vor hat es war winter alptraum
wie ein schlechter traum ich habe
manchmal gesagt kann es einfach sein das
ist ein traum ist und ich gleich
aufwache und ist einfach quatsch ist der
sieger der wahlen die globe kommt auch
diesmal aus frankreich yannick bester
wenn hat es im zweiten anlauf geschafft
die härtesten regatta der welt zu
gewinnen
für boris herrmann ist ein jugendtraum
in erfüllung gegangen und für seine
familie hat das bangen endlich ein ende
thomas tuchels 1 stand gestern abend als
neuer trainer vom fc chelsea eher
ernüchternd nur ein 0 10 0 gegen
referenten die meisterschaft die hakt er
ab und bleibt dennoch ehrgeizig titel
will er jetzt in den pokalwettbewerben
holen thomas tuchel ist im britischen
regen angekommen und musste sich nach
der enttäuschenden nullnummer seines
teams gleich einmal in zweckoptimismus
flüchten
ich bin sehr zufrieden mit der leistung
meines teams dass ich völlig offen für
unsere ideen gezeigt hat ein scherz ist
ihm hat es tuchel auch mit drei
deutschen nationalspielern zu tun
karl harms gestern hier in seiner besten
szene wie auch antonio rüdiger dessen
kopf weil man allen ernstes als chelseas
bester tormöglichkeiten ändern musste
und timo werner gestern nur auf der bank
wir sind in der lage jeden gegner weh zu
tun ganz gleich in welcher liga und in
welchem wettbewerb
bis dahin bleibt für tuchel mit seiner
mannschaft aber sicher noch bei
lauterbourg cdu also auf gut deutsch die
bürgerarbeit der deutsche wetterdienst
warnt vor starkem tauwetter im westen
und süden baden württembergs und am
bayerischen alpenrand wo es aber auch
glatt werden kann das sagt ihm gleich
ist intelli das war es von uns danke für
ihr interesse
das heute journal heute etwas später um
mit bettina schausten wir sagen tschüss
und hoffen dass sie morgen wieder mit
dabei ist in punkt 19 uhr einen
gemütlichen abend für sie
ein schon guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter quer über
deutschland liegt ein schneegebiet und
das verabschiedet sich vorübergehend und
morgen da an dem tagesverlauf kommt
neuer regen von südwesten her auf und
auch wieder quer über deutschland dann
ein schneegebiet was über längere zeit
an schnee produziert also es könnten
größere mengen zusammen kommen und es
ist mit größerer glätte zu rechnen durch
gefrierenden regen das bereits in der
nacht in diesem schraffierten bereich
nach südwesten gibt es viele wolken mit
teils dauerregen und tauwetter starkes
tauwetter in den bergen ebenfalls dabei
die temperaturen sinken auf 0 bis -6
grad nach nordosten hin und auf 10 grad
im südwesten
orientalisch verlauf wieder in diesem
roten schraffierten bereich teilweise
ergiebiger schneefall und gefrierender
regen über mehrere stunden und nach
südwesten ergiebiger regen und starkes
tauwetter bei temperaturen von null bis
minus ein grad dauerfrost im nordosten
und 12 grad im südwesten
das ganze wandert dann am samstag nach
süden in hier teils noch ergiebiger
regen minus 1 bis 10 grad oder ab
sonntag etwas kälter ein schöner abend